We have a another question here. Can you
address Nakes? And I think they're
referring to
Zachar.
Um Nakes claim that Genesis
3:15-16 saying that the birth is a curse
to women.
Well, why is these tr question troubling
you guys? I mean, it's just like the
second verse says, uh, something's
troubling you. Why are you spending time
listening to attacks on the faith? And
why aren't you studying your faith? And
I really suspect that this person may be
Muslim. If you're a Muslim, just come
out and say it because the name, right?
It's not even a name. It's a number.
1111D. You may have someone pretending
to wanting no answers.
So my first question would be why in the
world are Christians not spending more
time studying their faith and learning
from qualified learning men approved by
the Holy Spirit to know their faith
accurately. Why are they spending time
on channels attacking the faith? You
don't go to a channel that attacks your
faith if you're not grounded in your
faith unless you've already made up your
mind you don't want to be a Christian
and that's a different story. Right? But
now I would challenge
Naik because here it says saying that
birth is a curse. I would give him a
million dollars and I'll make Hussein
take shahada where it says giving birth
is a curse. That's not what it says.
Brother, can you open up Genesis 3 and
read verse 16?
Okay, let me get this off here. Okay,
it's okay then. That's okay, brother. I
don't know if you're brother sister, but
it'd be nice if we had a name and an
image or at least something so we can
confirm. But that's all right. I'll take
your word for it because you'll answer
to the Lord if you're lying. That's
fine. Can you read Genesis 3:16? Easy
number to remember. That's right. Okay.
Unto the woman he said, I will greatly
multiply your sorrow and and your
conception. In pregnancy is a curse.
Yeah. Yeah. In sorrow you shall bring
forth children, and thy desire shall be
to thy husband. He shall rule over thee.
Yeah. It doesn't say pregnancy is a
curse. He says, "Now, as part of the
judgment, when you get pregnant, your
labor
pains will be much worse, more
painful." It doesn't say pregnancy is a
curse. How can it be a curse when
already in Genesis 1
26 all the way to 30, God already
commisss the male and female to be
fruitful, multiply, and subdue the
earth? How are they going to be
fruitful, multiply if it's not through
pregnancy, human reproduction? That
Genesis
1:26-27, right? I mean, it's actually
you can read 2630, but 26 it says it.
Can you show them Genesis 1 26 to 30 and
read verse 26 for starters?
Okay. Genesis 1 26-30. That's the
section, but read verse 26 and then 27
so they can follow along.
I don't know if this one works like
this, but let me try it. Yeah, you do
26. No, no, no. Do 26 dash and then 30
dash. Not a You don't do No, no. You do.
Yeah. If you do Genesis 1 26-30, it'll
give you the entire section. So, you got
to go back and do it. Yep. Click on it.
Now, that's how you do it, brother.
Okay. And God said, "Let us make man in
our image, after our likeness, and let
them have dominion over the fish of the
sea, over the fowl of the air, over the
cattle, over all the earth, and over the
creeping thing that creepeth upon the
earth." So God created man in his own
image, in the image of God created he
him. Male and female created he them. So
the man that was created is male and
female, both male and female in the
image of God and have dominion. Now
notice the commission in 28.
And God blessed them and said unto them,
be fruitful and multiply and replenish
the earth and subdue it. And so wait,
you mean
reproduction is a blessing, not a curse?
Uh bless them and said be okay. Yeah.
So where did Nia get that pregnancy is a
curse? Genesis 1 told you it's a
blessing. God blessed them and said to
them, "Be fruitful." In other words,
reproduce, replenish after your own kind
through sexual intercourse, meaning
pregnancy and and birth. So, where did
Nia get that it's a curse? Because he's
a Bible pervert like his spiritual
father, the devil. It's right there.
Right. Now, finish it. You can read all
the way to 30. Okay. and have dominion
over the fish of the sea, over the fowl
of the air, over every living thing that
moves upon the earth. And God said,
"Behold, I've given you every
herbbearing seed which is upon the face
of all the earth, and every tree in the
which is the fruit of a tree yielding
seed. To you it shall be for meat, and
to every beast of the earth, and to
every fowl of the air, and to everything
that creepeth upon the earth, wherein
there is life. I have given every green
herb for meat. And it was so. So notice
the food, the meat that people ate prior
to the fall and prior to the flood was
herbs, fruits,
vegetables, no meat yet. meat meaning
flesh was given after the flood in
Genesis 9. But anyway, you saw here that
right there it says that
reproduction, replenishing the world
with
humankind with Adam is God's blessing,
not curse.
But the only way you can replenish,
reproduce humankind is through
intercourse, pregnancy, and then
delivery. Now go to Psalm 127, brother,
verses 3 and 5. Psalm 127:es 3 and
5. And read that for us.
Okay. Lo, children are a heritage of the
Lord. How can they be a heritage of the
Lord if pregnancy is a curse?
And the fruit of the womb is his reward.
How can it be a reward if pregnancy is a
curse?
As arrows are in the hand of a mighty
man, so are children of the youth. Happy
is the man who has his quiver full of
them. They shall not be ashamed, but
they shall speak with the enemies in the
gate. So notice, to have a lot of
children is a sign of God's blessing on
you because when you have a lot of
children, it's like you have weapons.
They will fight for you and defend your
honor.
Hallelujah. Amen. Okay. So where in the
world did Nia get that pregnancy is a
curse when pregnancy and childbearing is
actually a blessing of God upon
humankind. You know you know I just want
to say one thing about about about the
way Zachariah twisted that. Yeah. You
guys, this is exactly what they do, man.
That the word curse is in the next
paragraph. And he just took it and just
moved it up a few verses to say
something the Bible doesn't say. And you
guys, so much of what you hear in these
attack channels is just that they're
they're twisting and they're putting
things out of taking things out of
place. and and to hear this from Zachary
Nank, you know, someone who's got
millions of followers and and to to be
so
irresponsible in his twisting of the
scripture, you know, I mean, you you'd
expect him to at least try to be
logical, but he's not. And so for him
to, you know, and you could say, well,
maybe he doesn't sad, brother. You know
what's more sad? Here's what's more sad.
Not so much, Nike. Because remember,
sons of the devil, they're going to be
like their father devil. Didn't Jesus
say that to the Jews? You are like your
father, the devil who rejected him. Not
all Jews because first believers were
Jews.
Because if you're not a child of God,
then you're a child of the devil. And
you're going to have the nature of your
father and reflect the characteristics
of your father. So what does Satan do?
He's a liar. He's a deceiver. He's a
murderer. He's a slanderer. He comes to
destroy and steal. Look at the fruits of
Islam. And what did Satan do? Pervert
scripture by misquing Psalm 91 against
Jesus. So why would we be shocked that
those who do not fear Jesus and do not
know the true God are tools of the devil
are going to act like Satan, pervert the
Bible. So I expect that. What's sad is
what's sad
is that Christians don't know their
Bible enough and haven't studied their
Bible enough to be able to then call
people out like this and correct them
and expose
their gross perversion of scripture.
That's what's sad. Yeah. Yeah. You
expect children of the devil to birth to
the Bible, but why can't Christians know
their Bible? Yeah. And you know what
that makes me think? That's why, you
know, right now they're saying all these
Christians are leaving the faith and
they're becoming agnostic in the public
schools and everything. But Christians
aren't educating their kids to where
their kids can withstand it when these
attacks these attacks are going to come.
You know, they're out there. Satan does
the same thing all the time. And but you
know sometimes the kids you know like I
was you know one time I was a youth
pastor and then I would start talking
about the Trinity and you know these
kids are all born again kids. They've
been in church their whole lives and one
of them says oh yeah my aunt told me the
the trinity and he says it's like my my
my father can be an uncle and he could
be a grandfather and he can be a son.
Yeah. Yeah. Right. You see you get these
pathetic answers and then you wonder why
kids are confused and leaving the faith,
you know. So anyway,